morning everybody uh seven o'clock
welcome to the breakfast show here on
the sky news
do the right thing so we can put this
person behind bars police have made a
direct appeal to anyone who knows who's
responsible to help them catch the mass
gunman who killed nine-year-old olivia
pratt koval
she was shot dead in her own home as her
mum screamed for help we'll have the
latest from liverpool this morning on
the search for her killer
and ukraine marks its independence day
exactly six months since russia's
invasion in an exclusive interview the
nato secretary general that's jens
stoltenberg of course tells me that the
uk and other allied powers must spend
more to confront russia it's wednesday
the 24th of august
police plead for information to help
find the gunman who burst into her home
and shot olivia in the chest
as she was getting ready for bed
police say the killing of a
nine-year-old child crosses every
boundary as they appeal for help
also head as bombs fall on ukraine the
head of nato tells this program that
western nations will have to spend more
on defense to keep us safe from russian
aggression
faced with uh uh
russia's
military build up the will to use force
against the neighbors
there is a need to invest more in
defense
well good morning from the ukrainian
capital kiev where public celebrations
have been banned on independence day for
fear of further russian air strikes
rubbish piles up in edinburgh and it's
going to get worse with bin man across
scotland joining the strike
and using a hose pipe to water your
garden or clean the car is banned for 15
million people across southern england
from today
also coming up on the programme for you
this morning
ever heard of the dibbler or stick nest
rat they thrived in a remote corner of
the world 400 years ago survival expert
ray mayers will tell us about efforts to
bring them back
[Music]
and we'll be speaking to the little girl
who touched hearts around the world with
her performance of let it go in a kiev
bunker
[Music]
morning
merseyside police say they won't rest
until those responsible for killing
olivia pratt corbil are behind bars a
mass gunman shot the nine-year-old on
monday night as she chased his into as
he and chased his intended target into
her home detectives say anyone who knows
the killer's identity should look at
their conscience and come forward
uh fraser standing by for us in
liverpool this morning i mean this story
was unfolding yesterday morning wasn't
it fraser uh we had a news conference
from the police mid-morning yesterday
and the details of what happened in that
little girl's house came to light it
can't i can't begin to imagine how her
mum must be feeling this morning
morning kay yes the more details that
came out about this attack and the
killing of
of this nine-year-old girl olivia pratt
corbin the more
it beggars belief it's almost like a
scene out of a hollywood film or a
television police drama the incident
happened two men walking down the road
behind me chased by a gunman firing
shots at them indiscriminately in this
in the street and that was when olivia's
mum cheryl opened the door to see what
was going on
wrong place wrong time purely innocent
victims as she opened the door the man
who was being chased saw that as his
means of escape forced his entry uh into
the home and as he forced his entry into
the home the gunman followed he tried to
get in as well olivia's mum cheryl
trying to keep the door closed trying to
force the gunman out the gunman then
reached through the door uh firing his
weapon going a bullet going through
cheryl's wrist and into her daughter who
stood at the bottom of the stairs no
doubt coming downstairs after going to
bed to see what all the commotion was
about
then it almost
gets worse if it possibly could the the
gunman
then gained entry to the house fired
repeated shots into the into his uh
intended victim who was on the floor and
fled on foot that's the man the police
are now looking for but his victim the
man laying in the uh at the floor of
these stairs
his friends arrived in a dark-colored
audi car came into the house took him to
the hospital left him at the hospital
left the car there at the hospital as
well but also left olivia dying on the
floor at the foot of the stairs
incredible callousness to take care of
their own not to try and attempt to help
a nine-year-old girl who'd been shot in
the chest and was laying there dying
so it beggars belief as to as to the
thought process there but just imagine
what was going through cheryl's mind a
mother with with olivia and two other
siblings two of olivia's siblings in the
house as well trying to protect three
children from an unknown gunman who just
arrived at the door
at 10 o'clock at night you can only
imagine the horror the fear the fighting
instinct that she had to try and keep
those people out as they forced their
way into the home and a gunfight
basically ensued
in the at the bottom of the stairs in
their own home police say these people
have to be brought to justice they need
to know who commissioned this if this
was a targeted attack uh who the gunman
was where the weapon came from why he
was following this man uh details about
the man he's uh he was uh operated on
yesterday the man who had been shot by
the gunman a 35 year old man had
undergone surgery yesterday he still
hasn't been able to give police any
information they're still waiting to
question him because of his condition so
uh police are saying that someone must
know what's happened here someone must
know whether they are from the from the
community whether they're from the
criminal community uh that the killing
of a nine-year-old girl has crossed
every boundary and this is not a time
for keeping science there's no time for
any false codes of honor in order to try
and protect these individuals the man
responsible for killing a nine-year-old
girl still at large somewhere in the
merseyside force area they believe and
the situation now is that they think
that the public must be able to help
there will be someone who has that key
piece of information that can lead to
the man who carelessly shot and killed a
nine-year-old girl in her own hand you
reso you think if you've got your kids
at home with you they're safe you know
you never really know when they're out
and about this one was nine years old
she'd been playing with her friends on
the front there just behind you not an
hour before she was ready for bed her
mum thought she was safe a gunman breaks
in and shoots her in the chest at the
bottom of the stairs what impact has
that had on the rest of the community
a community like this is a close-knit
one it sounds like a cliche we hear that
phrase very often a close-knit community
but that's exactly what this is it's not
a transient community the people who are
born here grow up here and stay here
there are doors next door neighbors who
are family members there are extended
families living along this street
everybody knows everybody the children
all know each other we're hearing that
the children regularly play in the
street children from the ages of three
or four up to mid teens all play
together they all know each other this
will be a devastating blow to this
community to the parents who'll be
fearing for the safety of their own
children and for the children themselves
they've lost a friend a kind and caring
and loving young girl according to her
headteacher and according to the
tributes from those who knew her so at
every level at every age in this
community it's caused shock and no small
degree of fear okay thank you jamie
carragher um
liverpool celebrity of course footballer
he has been commenting on it he wants
stricter laws as far as carrying guns
and knives are concerned we're also
going to be hearing from the former
chief constable of greater manchester
peter
farhi from james heapey who is the
defense minister armed forces minister
he'll be joining us as well in just a
few moments time and also representative
from the liverpool echo how are the
papers looking at that story let's start
with the sun this is what they say
here we go gunned down at bedtime and
left to die
the eye describes the nine-year-old as
the youngest victim of gangland killings
and that's on its front page the express
calls olivia an innocent victim of gun
wars
the liverpool echo poses a direct
question to those involved in the
killing or anyone who may be protecting
them whose side are you on
and the guardian says it's learned that
the attempted killing of a senior gang
member led to olivia being mistakenly
shot dead
mistakenly shot dead he reached around
the door and shot her in the chest
russia's invasion of ukraine six months
ago has changed the world thousands of
people have been killed cities have been
reduced to rubble energy and food prices
have soared and the whole of europe has
been forced to reconsider its security
at the heart of west's response has been
nato's secretary general that's
jens stoltenberg in an exclusive
interview with me for sky news he said
the uk and other western allies
need to spend more on defence to protect
against the threat from russia
two percent is a minimum so of course we
welcome a uk and others
which are aiming at a higher
uh level of spending than two percent uh
because uh the brutal reality is that uh
faced with uh uh
russia's uh military build up the the
will to use force against the neighbors
uh there is a need to invest more in
defense
and you can watch that exclusive
interview in full a little later on in
the programme joined now by james heapey
the armed forces minister hello mr heap
you want to ask you about what jen
stottenberg has been saying to us but
first
i know that you are a father yourself
thoughts on the incident in liverpool
yeah my kids are about the same age and
um
you know the language that your reporter
used and as you just observed the
senselessness of
just reaching around a door and ending a
nine-year-old life is um
it's pretty shocking and it makes you
reflect on
how safe you do feel in your own home
what's extraordinary is that as your
reporter so eloquently set out
lots of people saw parts of what
unfolded in liverpool
and the police need those people to
understand that those who kill
nine-year-olds need to be brought to
justice and the information that they
hold no matter how fearful they may be
of sharing it
could be key to achieving some justice
for olivia and her family
everybody in government
wants those who saw what happened
yesterday to come forward with the
information they have so that merseyside
police can bring those responsible to
book
jamie carragher has called for an
increase
in the sentences for gun and knife
crimes is now the time to start looking
at that again
well i i don't think that
only a few hours after such a barbaric
incident it's right for a government
minister to to say that there must be a
policy change but i think moments like
this obviously focus minds and i'm sure
that when the new government comes
together it's those sorts of these sorts
of events that cause discussions for the
new home secretary and the new justice
secretary but i will leave it to them in
the meantime what everybody i hope
agrees is that getting information to
the police so that their investigation
can persuade quickly and the people
responsible be brought to justice is
what matters most
um as i mentioned just before we came to
you mr hippie we have an exclusive
interview with the nato chief that's jen
stoltenberg um a little bit later on
this hour um i spoke to him yesterday
and he was basically saying two percent
gdp is what nato countries are supposed
to pledge not all of them do i know that
you will tell me that the uk does i get
that he's saying
probably need more
yeah
and
i think that's right the security
situation in the euro atlantic has
profoundly changed uh in the last
year or so
and as we see tensions continue to rise
in
uh in the far east and the south china
sea so
it does feel like we are at a sort of
epoch change uh in our security
situation and thus the spending that's
required um in fairness liz trust who
i'm supporting to be our next prime
minister has committed to spending three
percent of gdp as you just heard yen say
was uh was
was now required uh she's committed to
do that by the end of the decade with
increases in defense spending every year
on the way to that but to be fair
because this morning i'm speaking to you
from a department of state and i don't
think it's right to use it as a platform
for a leadership contender rishi sunak
has also said he will increase defence
spending not quite to the same level but
nonetheless he has said that he will
increase that defense spending too
yeah at two and a half and three percent
respectively but you know we i also
heard from yen stoltenberg he said that
we are now on a cold war footing he was
talking about uh increasing the numbers
of nato troops from um tens of thousands
to hundreds of thousands uh our
percentage gdp spending during the cold
war was eight nine eight nine percent i
mean is that something that we might be
looking at
well look i mean three percent is uh a
fifty percent uplift in the defense
budget from what it was only a couple of
years ago
that is a huge amount of money with
which safeguards a number of really
important upgrades uh to the uk's
strategic and tactical capabilities
so
i think three percent by the end of the
decade is uh is a great commitment it
will transform our defense capabilities
um whether or not we ever need to get
back to the levels that were required in
the cold war depends on the success we
have in
containing russia
in its belligerence in ukraine
and in the way that the u.s chinese
relationship develops in the pacific but
three percent should not be
uh should not be dismissed as uh a as a
sort of interim figure three percent is
an enormous commitment for any
government to make and if we are led by
prime minister trust in a few weeks time
that's a commitment she's made and it
will mean
that beyond the u.s the uk remains by
far the largest defense spender in nato
and we will have set an example for
other european countries to follow yeah
but we're not ruling out doing what's
necessary in order to keep our people
safe are we of course not okay and no
nobody ever would not only in the
ministry of defense but around the whole
of government defense is expensive
um
but three percent is a very important
announcement okay
and that shouldn't be uh brushed aside
as not enough it would be the second
largest defense budget in nato
um so much of us um so many of us i
should say concentrating very much on
the cost of living crisis here at the
moment and that is very much linked to
the price of gas went up 34 earlier on
this week because of the situation in
ukraine and the reaction by russia um
at what stage do we have to think
as much as we have much sympathy for the
people in ukraine we need to make sure
that people in the uk are looked after
and we have to look again at what's
happening with our relationship with
russia
no i mean i think that i can understand
why lots of people
eating their breakfast and worrying
about the cost of living
will be
agreeing with the premise of your
question that you know there is a the
most arguably the most straightforward
solutions the cost of living crisis is
that
we re-establish relations with russia
and everything goes back to the way that
it was in the european energy market
every single thing that i have seen
in the last six months tells me that
that would be catastrophic for security
in the euro atlantic and thus not not on
some 10 or 15 or 20 year horizon
but within
just a few years we would find ourselves
in a situation where an emboldened
russia was causing cost of living
challenges that are
a hundred times worse than what we're
seeing right now because they
might seek to expand their ambitions
beyond ukraine and into nato territory
in the baltic for example
we have to
stand up for ukraine with ukraine so
that this all ends on zalensky's terms
because if we do not whatever the
short-term pain and cost might be
we set the conditions for security in
the euro atlantic and by the way an
emboldened president xi in the south
china sea to make the next 20 years on
this planet really uncomfortable really
dangerous and really expensive final
question before i let you go minister if
you wouldn't mind scottish power one of
the uk's largest energy companies has
proposed a plan to the business
secretary to freeze energy bills for two
years that would cost around 100
million a hundred billion pounds to give
me to put that into context that's more
than the furlough scheme cost in its
totality what's the government's
response
well these are eye-watering amounts of
money uh and yet
on the context of covid they're the
sorts amounts of money we speak of
routinely for
for interventions i don't think that a
universal freezing of everybody's energy
bill really helps to get taxpayers money
into the bank accounts the people who
need support the most that's why i think
that the more targeted
packages to be fair both leadership
candidates are proposing are probably
the better solution
but what everybody needs to know whilst
watching your show this morning kay is
that the government of the united
kingdom
is going to help them with the cost of
living there's lots that's already being
done but i know that it will be the
first prime minister and the first
priority for the new prime minister to
make sure that the government does more
to help them through the really
expensive winter that lies ahead
okay uh thank you minister as always
thanks kate
tamara is here with us morning thoughts
morning kate well
all the news dominated by the horrific
incident in liverpool yesterday and i
thought it was interesting that james
heapey said that for the next government
this would trigger discussions he didn't
go any further than that of course this
is not the time to play politics but
discussions about sentencing and about
policing and about law and order in
general because people in liverpool will
be
very deeply worried by what they've seen
yesterday and the fact that there have
been 14 fatal shootings in the city this
year but also they have been in other
cities as well and so he said that this
may end up being one of the big issues
in the entree of the next prime minister
whoever that is alongside of course the
cost of living and it seems liz trusted
supporters are very keen to reassure
people that she isn't ruling out help
for everybody and if that help takes the
form of an energy freeze costing a
hundred billion pounds because the
person who we think will be her
chancellor quasi quattang is currently
the business secretary he's having those
discussions with energy companies at the
moment who are putting forward those
suggestions it's not free it's a loan
and we would have to pay it back on our
bills in years to come but that is a
suggestion that is on the table and
certainly the energy companies say it's
being seriously considered in government
also interesting because we're going to
hear from stoltenberg in just a moment
or to the nato secretary general of
course um three percent uh 50 uplift as
he appointed uh 4g against the against
gdp for our spending um on defense he's
not ruling out that being more given the
threats not only from russia but also
china no liz trust has certainly in the
arms race of defense spending said she
would get to three percent that will
cost 10 billion pounds a year and of
course there are questions about where
that money comes from and rishi sunak
has said that he would put in more money
as the finances allow i think the uk is
also looking to other european countries
to step up their defense spending as
well because liz trust has certainly
been saying for some months before the
leadership contest even began that the
west was asleep at the wheel essentially
and now needs to step up for the
challenges that russia will pose in the
future okay tomorrow's take at nine
o'clock looking forward to it thank you
still to come on the program before you
speaking to peter fahey he's a former
police chief constable of greater
manchester about the killing of
nine-year-olds olivia pratt corville she
was shot in the chest
by a masked gunman in her own home
getting ready for bed
[Music]
and labour's shadow justice secretary
steve reed will be with me shortly after
eight o'clock
also speaking to germany's ambassador to
the uk asking him about his country's
commitments to ukraine after six months
of war
edinburgh living up to its name as old
reiki
scotland's capital is overflowing with
rubbish because of a strike by binman
that's now set to spread across scotland
here's james from edinburgh
from edinburgh's north shore you could
see the mist rolling in the city's bin
lorries were rolling nowhere
the bins are overflowing because of a
pay dispute at peak tourist time
refuse workers are halfway through a
12-day strike
low-paid members who are on the front
line during the pandemic let's not
forget they're already telling us
they're choosing between feeding their
kids and heating the house it's only
going to get worse when it comes to
october when the price cap goes up and
the heating goes on that's why we need a
pay rise now which does reflect the cost
of living crisis
you can see that i mean the street is a
disgrace
dean cassave owns a restaurant in the
center of town the bin strike is bad for
his business if we have another weekend
like the like the the weekend has just
passed
uh we're gonna have big big problems
with vermin
we we can't carry on like that
this is the heart of tourist edinburgh
business in scotland's capital continues
alongside the business of the strike
these scenes will be duplicated across
scotland in the absence of a deal to end
industrial action
refuse workers at more than a dozen
scottish councils are to stage walkouts
local councils blame the scottish
government for cutting their funding but
first minister nicola sturgeon denies
her administration is to blame we want
to see workers offered the fairest
possible pay deals in a situation an
inflationary situation that is difficult
for workers and for families across the
country the scottish government is
determined to support pay deals that are
as fair as possible it is the political
crossfire amidst a deepening industrial
dispute with no sign of immediate
progress
james matthews sky news edinburgh
a host pipe band comes into force for 15
15 million people across southern
england today the water company says
it's due to the unprecedented weather
conditions referring to months of hot
dry conditions
six water companies have now announced
hosepipe vans
metropolitan police are to review all
aspects of their investigation into the
search for the student nurse owami davis
after she was found safe and well in
hampshire she was located nearly seven
weeks after she was last seen
the 24 year old is being supported by
specialist officers
trades union congress is pushing the
government to increase the minimum wage
to 15 pounds an hour it's making the
call as the summer of strikes continues
across the uk and during a time when
workers have seen their pay lag well
behind soaring inflation
let's now return to the tragic events in
liverpool where criminals have been
urged to give up the gunman who killed a
nine-year-old girl
joining us now is former chief constable
of greater manchester and that is peter
fahey um hello to peter thanks for
joining us on the program this morning
um
tough time for the communities of
liverpool how do you start to keep a
city together when something like this
happens
well in the aftermath of an incredible
awful tragedy like this people do come
together um and you know serena kennedy
the chief constable has made it clear
that she needs the support of the whole
community but it's not just about
arresting this particular individual who
committed this crime it is about the
criminal network behind them um it's
whoever paid for this it's whoever
organized it whoever transported the
gunman to the scene you know is about a
whole criminal uh outfit there so it's
not just about this individual
horrendous crime it is about the fact
that often communities in some of our
cities have to live with this sort of
organized criminality around them and
subverting the normal system
operating things like the drugs trade
the market in stolen goods illegal money
lending whatever it might be um you know
it needs all the agencies and local
people working together long term
to undermine this
uh speaking about the chief constable
she is asked criminals in the area to
examine their consciences and cooperate
with the police from your experience do
they
it's very rare really you know this at
the end of the day will be down to
either a lucky piece of information uh
from the public uh really good analysis
of of things like mobile data mobile
phone data um forensics uh sometimes uh
another criminal gang will see it to
their advantage you know in a way
to pass the you know forward information
which might lead to the uh to the
disruption of another criminal gang
so you know this mate may be
cleared very quickly it may take many
many months a very detailed
investigation but as i say it is about
the long-term aim the long-term effort
to undermine these criminal gangs
as i say which cause misery to lots of
communities we often if we those of us
who live in nicer areas don't feel it
but the fact is
the market in stolen goods when cars are
stolen uh when things like watches are
stolen in some of the awful muggings
we're saying seeing in places in london
there are criminal gangs behind this and
what we saw with this awful murder
is the fact just the sheer villain you
know that the callousness and the
viciousness of some of these gangs who
are prepared to use horrendous level of
violence that's how they maintain their
power and their intimidation uh
sometimes innocent members of the public
get caught up in that but often when
criminal
members
suffer the most horrendous injuries they
refuse to cooperate the police or tell
the police what's happened because
either they want to exert their own
revenge or just out of fear
yeah what about this character who's in
hospital at the moment his mates came
picked him up left
basically walked over a dying child in
order to pick him up and take him to
hospital uh the police will want to talk
to him as a mattress emergency
absolutely and we'll want to talk to the
people around him and absolutely
investigate the whole background
exhaustively about this they may well
the police may well have a very good
idea about you know who's behind this um
what is the particular feud what's the
particular dispute that this has been
played out within
but the fact is you know they have to
get it to the criminal standard uh you
know to achieve a conviction and for any
arrests to be you know to ultimately
lead to a person being behind bars um
you know so absolutely they're going to
be investigating every different aspect
to that they're going to be relying on
cctv in the area but ultimately as i say
it's about long-term intelligence
gathering working with people like the
national crime agency and the regional
organized crime unit and other forces
but crucially other agencies in the city
of liverpool to share information to
share powers as i say not only to arrest
this individual but to you know take
apart the whole criminal network behind
them
olivia's mom will never
ever get over what happened in the
hallway of her home olivia's siblings
will never get over it but how do the
the police officers in liverpool the
police service in liverpool start to
make
other
um
neighbors feel safe in their own homes
well it's through you know really good
local neighborhood policing has been
there visibly in the local community um
it's about the local people having
confidence and the ability of their
police force
to take this apart and sadly merseyside
police great manchester police west
midlands police um are used to this
ongoing criminal activity and working
with the local people and trying to
reassure them uh but ultimately you know
people will only have confidence if they
see these criminal outfits being taken
apart and their power undermined and
local people have a role to play in this
but it often can be very very difficult
and people are going through really
difficult times and then approached by
people like illegal money lenders who
say that they're going to help them but
actually just horrendously exploit them
young people are drawn into the criminal
outfits into things like the county
lines networks and exploited and young
people who possibly could do well at
school um are attracted you know
thinking that they could be the next mr
big they could be you know the next
person driving around in a big bmw and
so these criminal outfits they create an
alternative value system and sometimes
almost uh trying to achieve an
alternative criminal justice system you
know and that's how deep-seated some of
this is um and why you know i know all
the agencies are working together and
sadly you know lots of police forces are
extremely experienced in dealing with
this and you know they'll be making
every effort now today to not only get
these people arrested but at the same
time trying to reassure local people and
making sure local people have confidence
you know in the system in the criminal
justice system you know in in in the
core agencies and don't feel that they
have to rely on criminal outfits you
know to help them get through life
okay so peter thank you
all that of course our top story on the
program this morning and police in
liverpool have appealed to the people
there to turn in the killer of
nine-year-old olivia shot dead at her
home
nato's secretary general jens
stoltenberg has told this program that
allied countries will have to spend much
more on defense
[Music]
we just heard from the armed forces
minister who agreed that the invasion of
ukraine has changed the situation
dramatically and said whoever becomes
prime minister the defense budget will
increase
well it is six months uh since the war
began in ukraine it's also independence
day in ukraine we were speaking to jens
stoltenberg the nato
chief and this is what he's been saying
to us
we are fundamentally doing two things we
are providing support to ukraine to help
them uphold the right for self-defense
against a brutal aggression of russia
and the other thing nato is doing is uh
to prevent this war from escalating
beyond ukraine
nato nato allah is not part of the
conflict and we have
increased the military presence
especially in the eastern part of the
alliance to send a very clear message to
moscow that if any nato ally is attacked
the whole alliance will respond and uk
is playing an important part in those
efforts
does that mean we are pushing ourselves
on a war footing
it means that we are supporting ukraine
in their uh defensive war against
the russian aggression and then it means
that we are
doing what we can to prevent the war
from escalating to directly involve nato
allied countries
and we do that
in the way we have actually preserved
peace uh
for more than 70 years as nato
by
having credible deterrence and defense
telling moscow clearly that
all allies will protect and defend
an ally which is under attack so so
that's the the way nato pursue peace and
it's even more important now
spending targets for nato members is uh
at least two percent that's that's the
hope that's the ambition during the cold
war britain's spending rose to almost
eight percent of gdp um are we entering
uh potentially from what you're saying
um
a sort of um cold war readiness where we
are going to have to look as member
countries at spending more to keep our
people safe
we need to spend more uh on the fence
and i have been a politician myself for
many many years and i
know that of course it's always more
tempting to spend on health care on
education on infrastructure
instead of spending on defense
but when we live in a more dangerous
world when we see the aggressive actions
of
president putin against a sovereign
peaceful nation in europe ukraine and
all the threatening rhetoric against
nato allies then we need to invest more
and that's exactly what
nato allies are doing the uk
all this spends more than two percent
but we need to do more together and uh
we need to invest in new and more modern
capabilities to ensure that we are able
to also protect all allies in the future
liz trust who may well be our next prime
minister i'm sure you're aware of that
is suggesting three percent of gdp here
in the uk by 2030 do you think that
would be enough or given what we're
looking at um and the situation in
europe at the moment we could find
ourselves in having to invest even more
as a percentage than that
the nato guideline is two percent of gdp
and my focus now is to ensure that all
allies meet that guideline the good news
is that more and more allies actually
spend two percent or more on defense
and those who are not yet at two percent
have most of them clear plans in place
to reach a two percent
then two percent is a minimum so of
course we welcome a
uk and all the others
uh which are uh aiming at a higher
level of spending than two percent uh
because uh the brutal reality is that uh
faced with uh
russia's
military buildup
the will to use force against the
neighbors uh there is a need to invest
more in defense what about deliberate
damage to a civil nuclear reactor in
ukraine which potentially could send a
plume of radiation westwards to nato
countries what would nato do then
that's a very dangerous situation and it
can of course also affect
people in nato allied countries but
there's a different thing that an armed
than an armed attack uh attack on a nato
allied the country uh the situation in
around or around the saporiza uh nuclear
power plant the biggest nuclear power
plant in europe is dangerous and it's
reckless of russia to deploy forces to
use the area around the nuclear power
plant as a launching pad for artillery
for attacks on ukrainian forces so
therefore
we need uh the international atomic
energy uh
uh uh agency to have uh access to be
able to inspect the uh the site we need
the russians
to
move their forces uh away from the
nuclear power plant and we need
the the the the ukrainian operators to
be able to do their work in a peaceful
and uh controlled environment because uh
what russia does around the sapariccha
nuclear power plant is dangerous and
it's dangerous for not only ukraine but
also for the whole of europe between
brexit
and and talks of other european
countries hungary sweden italy leaving
the eu and the nato withdrawal of
afghanistan this time last year
which do you think emboldened putin the
most to exploit exploit i should say
europe's perceived weakness and uh and
disunity and invade ukraine
putin invaded ukraine in 2014
then he illegally annexed a big part of
ukraine crimea and he started
to move forces and to
support the separatists in the eastern
part of donbass so
russian aggression against ukraine
didn't start in february this year it
started eight years ago
then of course what you saw this year
was a full-fledged invasion and that was
invasion invasion they have planned for
many uh months uh
nato allies uh actually predicted the
invasion uh so i think it's uh it's it's
it's no way to try to speculate whether
this is linked to afghanistan or any
other thing
the the reality is that
putin has an ambition and this is an
ambition that he's had for a long time
to re-establish
some kind of a
sphero influence where he can control
neighbors
and in particular ukraine and other
countries in its close neighborhood but
do you acknowledge that he is taking the
opportunity to exploit european disunity
so
what we see and therefore we need to
understand that ukraine is a highly
valued partner of nato we provide
support to ukraine but ukraine is not a
nato ally uh so the same security
guarantees that applies for all nato
allies united kingdom for all the allies
uh they don't apply for ukraine what we
have done for ukraine is that we have
supported them and again united kingdom
has been part of that especially since
2014 with more equipment more training
and that's reason why the ukraine armed
forces are much stronger much more
capable now than in 2014 and why they
have been able to fight back to stand up
against russia's brutal invasion and
actually we take some territory and uh
and and uh
also fight back so the russian offense
for instance in donbass has stalled so
that's our main purpose my main task is
to
continue to provide support ukraine but
if i may sir i mean you talk about it
not being a nato member ukraine neither
was afghanistan neither was bosnia
neither was kosovo and yet we sent
troops there um does nato regret not
answering the call quicker from ukraine
when they said the writing is on the
wall we need your help on the ground now
well actually we stepped up in 2014 and
uh and we have done a lot since then
nato and nato uh allies
uh and actually it was nato and nato
allies that warned clearly against the
invasion uh many months ago and we
predicted uh very exactly
uh the invasion and the playbook for the
war the the the aim of russia to try to
take kiev and we have no indication that
russ has changed its ambition when it
comes to
controlling ukraine uh but it is exactly
the support from the united kingdom from
all the nato allies that has enabled the
at least helped enable
the ukrainian forces to stand up against
the invasion
and president putin made a big strategic
mistake
uh when he invaded ukraine he thought it
could
take control of ukraine within days
now uh russia has uh uh
waged war against ukraine for six more
months and uh what we see is a war of
attrition where russia is uh
taking a lot of casualties because of
the courage and the capabilities of the
ukrainian armed forces and ukrainian
political leadership you've mentioned
2014 and the invasion the annexation
of crimea a couple of times there
should nato support ukraine's endeavor
to recapture it
we should support ukraine in the right
to uh defend themselves uh a right which
is enshrined in the u.n uh charter
ukraine nato is not part of the conflict
but we support ukraine then it's for
ukraine to decide uh uh
this war will almost likely end at the
negotiating table presidency has stated
that clearly but we know that what
ukraine can achieve on the negotiating
table is totally depend on the strength
on the battlefield and therefore the
best way we can ensure that
the negotiations lead to a result which
is acceptable for ukraine is to provide
military economic financial humanitarian
support ukraine now
so are you suggesting that potentially
president zielinski should be in a
position where he has to compromise on
sovereign territory that has already
been annexed by russia
it's for ukraine to decide our
responsibilities to support them as much
as we can with more
uh
support with faster
support and i engage directly with
political leaders throughout the
alliance
to speed up delivery of military
support
and then
presidency the ukrainian people how to
make the fine decisions on negotiations
and what kind of agreement they are
ready to go into
but the
aim of nato's support to the purpose of
nato support is to ensure that ukraine
can prevail as independent sovereign
state in europe we have to understand
that
the easiest way to end this war is for
president putin to stop fighting to stop
attacking
if president putin stops fighting we
will have peace if sedenska ukraine
stops fighting today and then ukraine
will cease to exist as an independent
sovereign nation so therefore we need
more military support to ukraine that's
my message okay but just to clarify are
you saying that if president zielenski
snares this war is not over until crimea
and uh the dumbass region of ukraine is
taken back into ukrainian suffering
control if he says not until that has
happened is this war over that is
something that nato would support
we will support ukraine
for as long as it takes we will support
ukraine to prevail as independent
sovereign
state in europe and then
this war will most likely end at the
negotiating table and the outcome of
that
will uh totally depend on the strength
on the battlefield and that's the reason
why we support them
well yuri sac is an advisor to ukraine's
minister of defense and is with us now
hello to you thank you for joining us
what was your interpretation of what we
were hearing there from jan stoltenberg
um
do you think that nato will support
ukraine
until crimea is brought back into
sovereign control
good morning and uh thank you for
inviting me uh of course uh we as an
independent sovereign country
uh fighting an aggressive war
we are counting on the support of our
international partners and we understand
that this is a war which ukraine is
fighting on its territory but this is as
well a war which ukraine is fighting for
the values of the whole of europe this
is a war which we are fighting for the
future the european freedom this is why
the support of our international
partners is vital
as for the crimean peninsula
crimea is
a sovereign territory of ukraine
it was illegally annexed in 2014 this is
an internationally recognized fact
and only yesterday there was a very
important meeting
in kiev
which is called crimean platform and
during that event
our president has said that ukrainian
crimea that the crimea was is and will
be ukrainian and when ukraine liberates
crimea and uh
reestablishes its control over its
sovereign territory the people of crimea
will again begin to live in freedom and
democracy
similar statements were made yesterday
by the polish president anja duda who
said that crimea is ukrainian as well as
mr erdogan the president of turkey so as
we can see there is an international
consensus with respect to the
legal framework within which ukraine
approaches crimea it is ukrainian
territory and it will be ukrainian
territory
yen stoltenberg also said that more
military support is needed by ukraine
what should that military support look
like
ukraine already received very important
military support from our international
partners
as we have seen after ukraine received
the for example uh the 155 caliber
cannons as well as multi-launch rocket
systems such as high mars and
m270 we were able to considerably
reduce the number of casualties and we
were able to disrupt
the russian aggressors supply lines
their logistics their ammunition
defaults this all resulted in the
stabilization of the front line
now we are entering now a stage of this
war in which ukraine will
most probably be preparing itself for a
counteroffen for liberating our
territories this means that we are in
dire need of further military assistance
in particular we need tanks we need
armored vehicles we need combat aircraft
and of course we need
missiles such as atacams missiles which
have along the firing range up to 300
kilometers because this will enable
ukrainian army to be even more efficient
to
strike with high precision and to make
sure that the war does not enter a
protracted stage which is not in the
interest of anyone
it's good to talk to you thank you very
much indeed for joining us on the
program thank you
thank you
aleister is in keo for us this morning
um hello to alastair good morning your
thoughts on what we're just hearing
there from the ukraine's minister of
defense and advisor too
and also what we heard from uh jen
stoltenberg before that
well i think what you're hearing from
the nato secretary general is um really
crystallizing the general thought across
europe and the united states and that is
that
nato and european allies are in this for
the long term and they are going to
stand by ukraine particularly through
what could be a very tough winter
financially for a lot of countries in
terms of energy bills and stuff like
that which i think vladimir putin is
hoping will uh create some cracks in in
the alliance but that doesn't seem to be
appearing and later today we'll hear an
announcement from the white house of a
new 3 billion
package of military equipment to ukraine
the largest uh donation yet from the
white house we don't know the details of
it but i think it's going to be longer
term stuff so it will signal that they
are going to stick by ukraine throughout
their fight to liberate their country
and what you were hearing in your last
entry there of course is please for more
equipment i think ukrainians feel that
the more that they put up a resilience
against the russians and show that they
can at the very least hold their ground
if not push them back then the more
willing uh their partners are to give
them more high-end equipment we've seen
that as really a narrative throughout
the six months as it's gone on they've
got better and more sophisticated
equipment and i think we could expect
that to be continuing through the coming
months as for today well it is a
bittersweet day it's going to be marked
pretty soberly certainly here in kiev i
mean look around me we're in one of the
main squares here it's very very quiet
and it's approaching mid-morning here
just to give you some figures some
sobering figures with the caveat that is
always very hard to know precisely uh
exact numbers but
num around 6000 civilians have been
killed during the last six months 350 of
those children more than 8 000
have been injured and then
six and a half million six and a half
million uh ukrainians have been
displaced from their homes either
internally or elsewhere in europe so
this has taken an enormous toll on the
country
independence day
independence from the soviet republic is
normally marked here with street parades
with street parties not today there is a
fear of further russian attacks either
on the capital kiev here or elsewhere in
ukraine so it's going to be very muted
and they will have their minds firmly
focused on what is happening to the east
and the south of here the fighting on
the front lines that goes on every bit
as viciously as it has done over the
last six months i saw the ukrainian
leader with his troops uh yesterday as
you said they've they've decided that
for even though it's independence day
any celebration any marking of that
event will be very muted and that's not
least as you were pointing out because
of concerns about what russia might do
yeah absolutely um the americans have
released some intelligence over the last
48 hours saying that they believe they
have information suggesting that russia
will somehow try and disrupt uh
independence day celebrations with
further attacks and enhanced attacks
president zielenski has told the nation
to prepare for something ugly
in this coming week and so i think the
reason for no major celebrations no
street parties is twofold i think it is
for people's security here to make sure
that they're largely staying at home and
different cities are doing different
things harkief which is uh further
closer to the russian border from here
there's a 48-hour curfew uh mikolai of
where i've been in the last couple of
days they're advising people to work
from home but here i think it is for
security reasons but also because of the
tone of the message it sends people of
course want to mark the independence
from the soviet republic and they will
want to show their support for the
soldiers fighting but they will be very
aware that any kind of sort of street
partying is just not in keeping not in
tone with what the reality is on the
ground in the east and the west
um okay for now thanks very much indeed
thank you
and the other thing that we uh want to
flag up we've not yet got her but we are
going to get her is do you remember that
little girl who was in the bunker in
kiev in the early days of the war and
she stood up on a chair and did this
[Music]
is
that was uh amelia she now lives in
warsaw with her mom and she's performing
at a concert tonight and we are
hopefully going to chat to it in just a
moment or two
before that though i want to talk to you
about the little girl in liverpool who
was about the same age until she was
shot dead uh in the hallway of her home
at 10 o'clock in the evening just being
put to bed by her mom um fraser is in
liverpool for us and as we were saying
at the start of the program froze as
this story developed through the day
yesterday it became um almost
incomprehensible what happened
okay the details of this the more
details we heard the more shocking the
story came became two men walking down
the street chased by a gunman one of
them uh uh
shots were fired one of them gained
access to uh to the to the house to
olivia corbell's house uh her mother
tried to prevent that man entering as he
tried to flee the gunman the gunman then
forced his way into the property and by
doing so he put his hand through the
door with the weapon fired the weapon
the bullet actually went through olivia
mother olivia's mother's cheryl's wrist
and into olivia's chest and as she lay
dying on the floor the gunman then fired
repeated rounds into the man that he'd
been chasing before making good his
escape friends of the man who'd been
shot then arrived at the property took
him to hospital leaving olivia dying on
the floor the vehicle that they taken
him to hospital in was left at the
hospital that man has undergone surgery
for gunshot wounds police still haven't
been able to interview him because of
his injuries and he has not yet been
arrested by police and so the hunt goes
on for the gunman five feet seven of
slim build at the time he was wearing a
black jacket black trousers black gloves
and a black balaclava so not much to go
on in the way of physical description
other than he's only five feet seven
tall and of slight build this is an
abhorrent act of evil says liverpool's
chief constable she says that this man
must be found and that this is no time
for any code of silence no time for any
false sense of honor against uh within
the criminal fraternity that they should
come forward and give the information
that the police need to try and make a
crucial breakthrough in the search for a
gunman who forced his way into a home
shot dead a nine-year-old girl and then
made good his escape but there's been a
number of firearm related crimes here in
liverpool in the in recent days and
police say that this man must be brought
to justice i want to ask fraser about
this character that's in hospital at the
moment what do we know about him
35 years old we know that he was walking
down the street with a friend when he
was chased by the gunman whether he was
the intended target whether this was a
random shooting whether this was a
targeted attack still not clear by
police there was another shooting just a
couple of days ago ashley dale a 28 year
old woman just a a mile and a half away
from from the scene here she was shot
and killed in her own garden when again
an an unknown gunman forced his way into
her property began shooting
indiscriminately she tried to escape and
was shot and killed in her own garden so
the situation regarding that police
haven't yet linked to those two
incidents but it's unclear yet whether
this 35 year old man was the intended
target he clearly had friends in the
area they arrived in a car which was
later left abandoned at the hospital
after they'd taken him there but clearly
there is
no honor amongst any of these people the
situation their friends taking this man
to hospital police said it would have
been clearly obvious to them that olivia
was there that olivia had been seriously
injured there was no way that they could
not have seen that this young girl had
been seriously injured with a gunshot
wound to her chest and instead they
chose to help their friend take him to
hospital and leave olivia to die
and her mum her mum was shot in the hand
what do we know about her mum
yeah gunshot wounds through the wrist as
she tried to prevent the gunman gaining
access to the property olivia and her
two siblings in the property at the time
you can only imagine the horror that
that cheryl was feeling as the gunman
tried to force his way in the gunshot
wound to her wrist she is in hospital
she has received treatment for that she
remains in a stable condition in
hospital rosa thank you very much indeed
thank you we'll have more on that coming
up in just a few moments time also the
very latest on what's happening in
ukraine that to come in just a moment